this is your taxi this is a friend of
yours who is staying with you last night
yeah yeah
um can you just describe what happened
last last night well we were talking
with each other you see we're just in
the house and suddenly I heard he's
shouting and noising you know everywhere
and then the youngster was shouting you
know like verbally abusing you know so
but honestly it was terrible I've never
ever seen like that situation in my
lifetime it's really terrible but 100
people maybe and it was just ridiculous
it was just like I meant to be in work
right now and I can't go because I've
had no sleep people's beans were being
stolen lit on fire
I stuck my mum a back Garden to mine
didn't get stolen that's when Eva's car
so I didn't get smashed in people have
lost their lives during this so
Mike has nothing when
two people have sadly passed away so